I give this to you I want you to have
this with my blessing you guys the
mustard
[Music]
oh yeah Reds a bit like toilet roll at
the moment isn't it it's like gold dust
you got oh you gotta hunt that stuff
down I was lucky enough to get one of
the more sort of cheapest lows like it
finds I was get a sense that these are
the kind of lows that you tend to use in
an american-style grill sheet yeah
absolutely it's got a reasonable sugar
content so it's it caramelizes
beautifully grilled cheese isn't
supposed to be arty okay this thing
we're doing here this is this is like a
freebie I'd only doing this just to to
improve your life this thing is better
with a hangover
it's better with cheap cheese you know
how most great artists want to leave
something for the future for posterity I
give this to you I want you to have this
with my blessing and you can pass it on
to your children in the fullness of time
what sets it apart from their sort of
typical totally cheese sandwich I've had
grilled cheese when I've been to the
States and there's something almost a
bit disgusting about it which makes it
so delicious all the things your body
wants it's its fats its salt its dough
it's all those things point at one place
but here we're going to improve it even
better there so take your two slices of
bread and grab your mayonnaise and smear
it on both pieces of bread heat up your
pan do I put any fat into that much more
exciting than that this is absolutely
the same ways that can cure anything
working for take a slice of bread put it
in the pan mayonnaise side down
mayonnaise down onto the on an oiled pad
yeah now carefully put the cheese on top
and put the second piece of bread on top
of that mayonnaise side up got you good
a bit of cheese overboard doesn't matter
this fine move the sandwich around to
sort of pick up the built the leaky
cheese so why mayonnaise on the outside
of the bread and butter basically by
using mayonnaise what you're doing is
you're frying the bread the same as you
would on a regular grilled cheese but
you're also having a kind of lovely
delicious flavored omelet ething to it
as well I'm salivating thinking about
this yeah yeah huh I told you change
your life
over and lick any remaining mayonnaise
off your fingers is this the classic
American style they but they always put
their mayonnaise on the outside they
don't always but the good ones do and
the cheese inside is looking gooey and
delicious
move the sandwich around in the oils and
fats and greasy bits so it picks up the
last bits it's looking like it might be
done the cheese is beautifully melted
inside but it also applied if you want
to you can lift and put onto some
kitchen roll and dab the fat off it oh
no goodness no that would be a waste
wouldn't it if you do we cannot be
friends
that's it forever all over them you are
dead to me
a bit keys are starting to ooze out now
oh it's a good feeling isn't it what's
your point oh my goodness you could also
think of it like a steak so you need it
to rest for a little while as well just
for all the little bits inside it to
sort of become promiscuous as it were
and blend and also it's too [ __ ] hot
to put it away medium and knife straight
through oh that's just a thing of beauty
[Music]
yeah oh yeah mm-hmm
sandwiches one of those many long
evenings we've got ahead of us
maybe feelingly a little bit blue about
the months ahead in isolation make one
of these somebody said the other day
that they don't feel like keeping some
of their older wines anymore life is too
short to put these things off I've got a
200-pound bottle the cote de rhône I
found at the bottom of the wine cellar
and I'm gonna drink it with a grilled
cheese sandwich next week we got the
load of time coming up when we're gonna
have weird and random ingredients coming
in and quite a lot of time to spend in
the kitchen I hope and what's nice about
something like that somebody's it's
probably the first thing you'd learn a
catering college
it's absolutely the simplest most basic
tool to play with add some milk to the
basic paste and maybe some chicken stock
and you've got prima chicken soup if you
add meat stock to it you've got a thick
dark gravy we're actually gonna thicken
some beer to make the basis of a sauce
will should have a lot of cheese in it
as well which you can then use to make a
Welsh rarebit which is a brilliant snack
a really really easy thing quite a child
please are quite a crowd-pleaser as well
[Music]
stick a slice of bread in the toaster
don't hang out on too dark a lump of
butter here about the size of a tape to
do all right space something there
though smaller than that little smaller
half that as that but it's melting at to
it roughly the same amount of flour to
divide the two together I'm gonna put a
spot more but for a mine actually more
but it's not gonna hair is it sort of
smell are you getting off yours okay so
they'll be adding more butter might
start to bubble up a little bit no
public is good the whole thing here's to
use a terrible terrible chef Ito is to
cook out the flour how long would you
would you cook out the flour until you
get this kind of biscuit II smell room
I'm getting out rich rich tea biscuits
okay so no mu beer this is all I had
lying around Newcastle Brown class act
so it immediately bubble up and then go
incredibly lumpy so you add more beer
and keep stirring each time my beer why
we're doing this with beer and not a nut
milk eyes out I suspect you would do
normally because beer and cheese is an
amazing delicious combination mine's
gone like scrambled eggs that's okay
keep stirring it's not more like it yeah
that's right
okay stick a couple of teaspoonfuls at
least of English mustard in there
I've got Dijon is that okay Dijon will
be absolutely fine then a big shot of
Worcester sauce dump in your cheese the
other thing you can do it's really
really good with it is put it in baked
potatoes so this time you can also add
if you want to things like Tabasco
black pepper and you've got a kind of
gloop now yeah now you taste it and see
what else it needs - almost a sausage
I'm gonna give mine an Indian twist
I recommend this stuff highly enough
I've always wanted to lay this stuff
that on greaseproof paper let it go cold
and you could slice it into squares the
same as that really bad American burger
cheese oh wow that this would be the
ultimate burger slice this Guinness and
I noticed middle the after
but you know we're in lockdown right
it's got to be done it's almost like
Christmas isn't it being in lockdown -
the seasonal cheer good oh yeah
smear it on top right to the edge yeah
thicker and heavier in the middle Oh
somebody seems to have leaked onto my
finger oh no mm to shove it under your
grill wha think up think I've saved it
in the nick of time
okay I'm going to show you a trade
secret here basically you take a knife
don't cut it just push down into the
cheese in the top like this something
like this watch one two three and then
one two three so you cross-hatched the
top with grooves that gives you a place
for the extra Worcester sauce to run in
through the cheesy cover I think it's
just the most beautiful thing
[Music]